Husband has been loving Snickers bars
and when he was craving one today
I just decided to make him a batch myself.
Started off by making some peanut butter by just blending up some dry
roasted peanuts.
Once that was all smooth,
I set that aside and got started on my new GOT.
I combined all of my ingredients,
which were sugar and water, and let that come to a boil on the stove.
While that was boiling,
I separated my egg whites from my yolks
and made sure to have them come up to room temperature
before whipping them until medium stiff peaks were forming.
Once that was the case,
I took my sugar mixture off the stove and slowly
poured it into the egg whites
and mixed it on medium high speed until it turned into a marshmallow
fluff consistency.
Then I spooned it out onto my baking sheet
and realized that it was a little big,
so I transferred it over to my square baking dish.
Once it was pressed down,
I popped it in the fridge for about five hours
before starting on my caramel.
I combined some sugar and salt,
let that melt on the stove.
Once it reached this amber color,
I whisked in some heavy cream and butter.
Then I incorporated some peanuts
and let that cool slightly on the stove
before pouring it over my set nougat.
I turned my baking dish to the fridge for the caramel
to set for another 30 to 45 minutes
while I melted some chocolate.
Then it was time to dip my bars in the chocolate.
So I pulled it out the fridge,
cut it into 12 equal pieces
before taking one of them and dipping it in the chocolate
and letting it cool down on a wire rack in the fridge.
And there we had our Snickers bar.
Lucky was so surprised at how good they were,
and he definitely approved.